the Affordable Care Act may be going
back to the Supreme Court after a
federal judge ruled the entire law
unconstitutional Friday's ruling follows
the Republican tax overhaul that changed
Obama's individual mandate by removing
the tax penalty for people who are
uninsured the Texas judge ruled the law
cannot stand without it if the decision
is upheld it would eliminate protections
for nearly 20 million Americans who are
insured through Obamacare now that could
upset the entire health care system the
Kaiser Family Foundation estimates that
27 percent of adults under 65 have
pre-existing conditions that could leave
them uninsurable CBS News business
analyst Jill Schlesinger is here with
what the ruling could mean for your
health insurance okay first let's talk
about those who are covered by the
Affordable Care Act the most important
thing to note is your coverage is intact
this does not change anything for 2019
if you enrolled you went through that
window which closed on Saturday for the
vast majority of states you've got your
coverage there are 11 states and the
District of Columbia
they have different programs they have
their own state exchanges those each
have their own deadlines for enrollment
so if you are considering that don't
listen to this and say oh I shouldn't
enroll you absolutely should enroll
again coverage intact for 2019 because
this legal fight could go on for years
what about those who are covered through
work or private insurance and
specifically have pre-existing
conditions this is the big concern and
again don't freak out just yet we don't
know how this is going to turn out it
will likely end up in the Supreme Court
but the thing about Obamacare is that
there were two aspects of it it had it
really have mandated that everyone
should be able to get health insurance
and that if you had a pre-existing
condition you couldn't be treated
differently and so now if this is ruled
unconstitutional if it's dismantled it's
not the 20 million or so who have
Obamacare who are impacted it is also
the folks who have pre-existing
conditions a health care expert I spoke
with yesterday said to me his big
concern is that because these changes
are looming people are really
start freaking out about it and they
really shouldn't yet but this is a big
concern one of the other things that
people forget about Obamacare as well is
that it mandated that insurance cover
lots of preventive care that's exactly
right
for women for lots of other expanded
coverage in terms of the insurance
umbrella and with all those different
things that had to be covered and and
you know it is a list is lengthy the
other idea here is that if those things
aren't covered maybe we go back to a pre
Affordable Care Act era where people are
not covered for as much but not only
that we could see this actually
dramatically impact people especially
with small employers and these smaller
plans are not going to be as expanse I
don't think it'll be as dramatic for the
larger employers we also see that
signups for the ACA are down 12% how's
that affecting things well I think this
is a big problem because especially in
those 11 states in DC they want
enrollments up part of the problem is a
slightly shorter period not as much
advertising and I think that this is
really conspired to create a bit of a
difficult situation on the up side some
states had expanded Medicaid so some
people fell in under that but again this
is an incredibly important issue I don't
want to make everybody knot of nuts
about it because there's nothing to do
today but it is really going to impact
millions of piece so quickly we know
that a lot of state attorneys generals
are already appealing what happens next
so now this winds its way through the
court system and as one lawyer said to
me I don't know how John Roberts is
going to wake up the morning that case
comes to him but we know that the Chief
Justice had ruled in favor of the large
portion of the Affordable Care Act when
the previous case got to the Supreme
Court we don't know yet again important
issue everyone please do get your
coverage if you are still eligible for
your enrollment period Jill thank you